Welcome back everyonemy full ms marvel episode 1 video there are so
many easter eggs connections to all the marvel
phase 4 movies avengers end game pretty much
everything in the mcu right now and there's
a couple easter eggs for other big stuff
like she-hulk and there's even a big direct
connection to the events of spider-man no way
home which just happened so i will explain
everything if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes
we're doing a disney plus giveaway for
memberships all you have to do to enter is just
be a subscriber and leave your favorite easter
egg from the episode on the video careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode yet i'll
just start at the beginning and we'll work our
way through scene by scene talking about easter
eggs big connections wtf moments as we go along
kamala khan is a relatively recent character
to be introduced in marvel comics she debuted
in 2013 during captain marvel number 14. the way
they did the series is they treated it more like
the tone in the vibe of spider-man homecoming like
it feels a lot like spider-man homecoming with her
in school and for obvious reasons there are many
easter eggs and direct connections with characters
from spider-man no way home spider-man far from
home and spider-man homecoming she's located in
jersey city on the other side of manhattan from
where spider-man is so she's way closer to the
events of wand division in west view so she'd
know all about that but the big change they
made to her in the comics is that in the comics
she's actually an inhuman and they just kind of
reintroduced that during doctor strange 2 with
black bolts showing up thank you very much but
because they don't exist on the main earth of the
mcu right now they decided to change her powers to
make them more similar to captain marvel's and
monica rambos so that during the captain marvel
2 the marvels movie they all work a little
bit better on screen together that's why her
power looks a little bit more like the energy
coming off of monica rambo during wandavision
the way they're explaining her powers too
is that she's using what seems like the cree
version of the nega bands which is a callback to
the first version of captain marvel the marvel
character they convert mental energy into physical
energy so the real shorthand is that she has green
lantern powers but the big difference is that as
you can see later in the episode they leach energy
from other electrical devices to power themselves
up the reason they have them do that is so that
when she's standing next to captain marvel who's
kind of like a cosmic power battery she is a near
infinite energy source to power them up so she
can continue being a superhero for much longer
when she's fighting with captain marvel
originally in the comics she debuted as
an inhumans character her powers were activated
when thanos set off a terrigen bomb of the ms
in new york city just like on the tv show she was
an avengers fan girl she wrote a lot of her own
avengers fan fiction she was a big captain marvel
stan so when she got her power she was wearing a
captain marvel costume and eventually wound up
changing that to her own version that you see
and she'll eventually get during the series the
actress in real life said that she grew up being
a marvel stan so she's watched all the marvel
movies she's just as big a fan as anyone else
she even tried to work in a bunch of iron man
easter eggs and references to all the episodes but
kevin feige said no no don't do that we want her
to be more of a captain marvel fan like the comics
she also said that she tried to work in a bunch
of inhumans easter eggs during the episodes too
like she was trying to get lockjaw the dog into
the episodes i think is a stuffed animal in her
room because she has a lot of stuffed animals and
avengers merch all over the place kevin feige also
vetoed that just because they weren't ready to
introduce actual inhumans in the mcu in this way
she also said that she got into arguments with
kevin feige about whether or not the real mcu
is actually the 616 universe is canonized by the
doctor strange 2 movie thinking that it was still
the classic earth 1999 it sounds like way back
when marvel tv became a really huge thing with
agents of shield after the first avengers movie
she became a huge stan of those characters too
the actual episode title is generation y which is
meant to be a reference to ms marvel volume 2 by g
willow wilson one of the creators of the character
they based most of the story of the actual series
on her run of the ms marvel character generation
y is also meant to be a reference to her letter y
generation differentiating her from the older
avengers marvel characters like the marvel phase
1 heroes even though thor is over 1500 years
old most of them except for like nick fury for
instance are gen xers the whole generation y in
the context of the mcu is just meant to be like
the next group of heroes to come along like the
young avengers because it does sound like they're
building up to a young avengers team eventually
introducing all those different characters from
the comics in different series they play that same
song by the weekend from the early trailers over
the marvel studios title sequence and they give
it a new upgrade to the standard marvel studios
logo like there's some new footage incorporated
from the recent series and movies and they also
give her a fully custom version of the marvel
studios logo like they've done for some of the
disney plus series they feature footage of captain
marvel more prominently because of obvious reasons
the brand new footage that they put in is
from doctor strange 2. this is right out of
the trailers with him opening the eye of agamotto
there's even a brand new scene from moon knight
in the letters here at the end too the custom
homemade looking version of the logo with the
paper mache version in the person's hands is meant
to be her is meant to be part of her avengers fan
films that she creates for her youtube channel
but this is meant to give you some context for the
character and why she's such a fan girl of captain
marvel because during the series especially during
this episode they make a lot of references and
jokes to the fact that nobody actually knows
that much about captain marvel because she's
never around she calls this the final chapter
in her 10-part series on captain marvel she
calls her earth's mightiest hero that's the
phrase used in the classic avengers comics earth's
mightiest heroes funny connection to thor love and
thunder on thor's trucker hat when he's getting
all swole it's got the classic avengers logo
and comic book phrase on it with him writing over
it in sharpie saying strongest avenger pretty much
all the logos in this referencing anything going
on with any character related to any of the movies
or the disney plus series is based on comic book
font but basically her final episode here that
she's created is the avengers endgame final battle
and when she says it's the conclusion of a 10-part
series it's a clever reference to the end of the
infinity saga of movies because we're in marvel
phase 4 now just to chart this series in the
timeline this takes place about two years after
avengers end game there are references later in
the series during her gym class to it being the
year 2025. there's also a reference on her desktop
to something coming up in september so it's meant
to be like in august like the very beginning
of the school semester she's also a junior in
high school she's 16 years old so she's about
as old as spider-man was during far from home
there's a version of hella here there's also a
brunette version of captain marvel this could be
a depiction of her because she's like the only
brunette ms marvel that i've ever seen before
you notice in the background there's a bunch of
doodles on white paper this cat here is just meant
to be goose the flerkin not an actual cat but
this is actually one of the depictions of carol
danvers as ms marvel before she started calling
herself captain marvel just to sort of foreshadow
kamala khan becoming ms marvel but in the context
of the mcu nobody on this earth has ever used the
term ms marvel when talking about carol danvers is
like a brand new concept throughout this too all
the depictions of the characters are all based
on comic book designs is the same thing around
her room too it's all captain marvel comic book
art and when we get to the avengers con later
i'll point that out too because it's basically
wall-to-wall easter eggs with a bunch of comic
book art the sloth with the wings is a reference
to her sloth baby productions youtube channel name
this captain marvel artwork is a combination
of modern artwork along with classic jack kirby
artwork like you see the kirby crackle here this
ms paint version of captain marvel is meant to
be an old old-school computer joke because it's a
free version of the software that you don't have
to pay for like adobe or other more complicated
artwork programs so if you use pcs back in the
90s or the early 2000s you probably used a
version of ms payne at one point we learned
that scott lang started his own podcast after
avengers end game in the mcu called big little me
which is a big ant-man pun talking about the
avengers quantum energy being ant-man in general
his adventures with the other avengers characters
the title this powered life is also a play on the
npr podcast this american life this is more of
her during the battle of avengers end game going
up against thanos ships the circle q logo is just
foreshadowing bruno's family's business they run
the corner store it's sort of like their version
of mr delmar's bodega during the spider-man movies
when she calls her a well-quaffed hero she's
joking about captain marvel's mohawk from the
comics which they've done in the movies a couple
times they also depict her with a couple different
comic book haircuts i believe the ko joke that she
uses here like the audio is directly taken from
street fighter 2 game like kamala khan in real
life just borrowed audio from street fighter 2 for
this then when she's guessing what captain marvel
has been doing while she's been in deep space
increased scroll space all these years they play
a bunch of classic sci-fi footage this alien is
just meant to be a funny twist on comic book saves
she depicts her having a bunch of adventures with
other aliens it's meant to be kevin feige just
cleverly winking revealing what's actually been
going on in the mcu just filling in that backstory
then she references the avengers con which is like
the in-universe version of comic-con but just
for avengers stuff and this is meant to be the
inaugural year this sign that reads carol core
is an actual thing in real life in the fandom she
says one of her next videos is going to be about
how she thinks thor is secretly a gamer which is
actually correct because we saw avengers end game
it's a big joke on that new master fortnite scene
when she says a new episode drops every
wednesday that's a big disney plus joke because
marvel drops their episodes on wednesdays this
scene is just depicting her family and friends
you could say this person wielding the sword is
an eternals black knight camelot reference too
just because it's so different from a lot of the
other references that she makes in her fan films
all of her recent videos are meant to be sort of
clever updates on the marvel phase four timeline
like things that have been happening in the past
couple of years in the mcu like before her carol
danvers video there's a video about ant-man and
the wasp vacation in paris it's meant to tell you
literally what they did after the events of
avengers end game like we see what you're doing
here kevin feige giving us all this backstory this
is like the most expensive exposition fan film
ever the video beneath it bitten by a radioactive
feminist is a spider-man joke on the actual spider
bite then some of you actually recognize some of
these youtube jokes like there's a spammer in her
comments trying to pretend to be a normal
commenter scamming people getting them to
link away to a website where they'll give their
personal information there's a comment from her
best friend bruno who left a comment a couple days
ago and i can't see all of her video titles on
the right rail here but these would all be other
marvel phase 4 references too to like big things
that are happening in the universe right now
there's a big joke about her taking her driving
test into just going terribly they say they wrote
the series in the tone of spider-man homecoming
with the same vibe but also when they were
doing spider-man homecoming they filmed him
taking his driver test for an audi ad the
t-shirt she's wearing is an in-universe avengers
shirt joking about the wasp valkyrie and
captain marvel are wearing eyeglasses
then when she crashes the car and they play the
title scenes for the ms marvel series these are
all titles based on the ms marvel comic book
titles they have this whole thing during the
episode where they show her daydreaming but they
show you what she's seeing with captain marvel
in fan art flying by her mother starts yelling at
her about daydreaming and then references kamala's
grandmother saying that she's just like kamala
setting up everything that's going on with the
kree nega bands in the new powers that she gets
they make it sound like her grandmother will be
a bigger thing in the series like she used to wear
the bracelet and use the powers back in pakistan
where their family came from when they take her
to school in the morning all the names on the
plaque here are people who actually worked on the
real-life ms marvel comics g willow wilson helped
create the characters stephen wacker jamie
mckelvie all these people all marvel comic
book writers and comic book artists and during
school there are actually several moments that
are very similar to spider-man homecoming moments
with him at school like she's trying to get her
books for chemistry class we saw spider-man in
his chemistry class making new webbing this is
bruno from the comics he's her best friend it
sounds like they're doing a relatively comic
book accurate story for him but also incorporating
some more tech based stuff to his character they
set up this whole subplot with a zoe character
who's kind of like her frenemies in a mean girl
kind of way who shows up later i think she's going
to be like the flash thompson to her peter parker
so she'll act terribly to kamala khan not really
caring about her but she'll secretly wind up being
a stan of this new mystery ms marvel character
without knowing that it's actually kamala khan
her guidance counselor gabe wilson is named for
the comic book creator g willow wilson and when
they have the big joke about planning her future
and he starts quoting mulan they actually use the
same film technique that they used during
the mulan movie when they split the screen
when they're at the circle cube bruno references
darth vader and i think this is the second
character outside of spider-man in the mcu
to directly reference a specific star wars
character or movie then when they're brainstorming
different versions of the captain marvel costume
and mashups of different characters they also pass
a building named green co another hulk reference
there are many during the series they reference
a mashup of captain marvel in black panther iron
man captain marvel doctor strange calling them
captain panther iron marvel doctor strange marvel
there were actual comic books when they did stuff
like this but there was a comic book where captain
marvel tried to actually learn magic from doctor
strange the big comic book team up between captain
marvel and black panther is literally happening in
the ultimates comics but also in real life fans do
this all the time mashing up different versions of
characters together to create something a little
bit cooler she references valkyrie wearing a cape
and the winged horse that we see during the thor
loving thunder trailer also asgard in present
day is a much more common tourist attraction
for the rest of the world they make a joke about
a princess match up with captain marvel with her
wearing a tiara that they pay off later in the
episode she makes a marvel zombies joke about
zombie captain marvel they did marvel zombies
during what if were you gonna get what if season
two so we might see them again they kind of had
a marvel zombies easter egg during doctor strange
2 and they were also making a completely separate
spin-off series about marvel zombies for next year
this upside down shot is her watching an episode
of the felicity tv show which is a bit of a
deep cut but it's of two of the protagonists
having their very first kiss it's meant to be
a reference to her in bruno's relationship the
way they set the two of them up is that they'll
probably eventually become a couple by the end
of the series then when she discovers these
cree nega bands from her grandmother's box they
rotate the camera around it's meant to mirror
the scene of her activating her powers later in
the episode of the avengers convention when the
camera spins around again the writing on the band
the symbols the energy seem like they're very cree
themed her grandmother is still alive like i said
it sounds like there's going to be some backstory
here with explaining how it is that she got her
hands on crete technology like this and as i said
they're designed based on the original captain
marvel marvel's mega bands from the comics they
do a bunch of errands in their version of little
pakistan touring all the shops and the restaurants
them cutting the meat off the spit here is
another clever avengers reference to the shawarma
post credit scene another big spider-man reference
here too the street food vendor mentions vultures
when he talks about vultures and armani suits
though that might turn into an actual bigger plot
in the series but the actual mcu vulture himself
just got teleported to the morbius venom universe
in the morbius post-credits scene the bruno
character seems kind of like a dumpster diver in
the same vein as spider-man and iron man he's the
one who makes the photon gloves for her costume
later photon also a big reference to monica
rambo's name that she used during the comics
they do have a small montage of her creating
her cosplay version of the costume using the
sash meant to be like the classic ms marvel
costume eventually she will make her own comic
book accurate version of the upgraded costume
too the funny thing about this hulk scene with
her parents trying to get her to dress up like
the hulk is that she goes full fangirl which is
very much a thing in real life like you're not
doing it correctly there is no little hulk in
real life the closest thing we actually have to a
little hulk would be like the smaller in stature
she hulk which is actually gonna debut episodes in
august so it's a bit of a clever reference to that
but she's not exactly little she's like eight
feet tall when she's hooked out like i said in
the background of this gym scene they kind of
chart the timeline for you like there's a big
gap between 2019 and 2023 because that's basically
when the snap took place on the far right you see
the 2024 pendant that's for last year's season
meaning this year is 2025. so this is like the
furthest forward we've been in the marvel phase 4
timeline besides doctor strange 2 in the events of
thor love and thunder when she's going through her
elaborate montage of how they're going to get into
the avengers convention and sneaking at the house
she does a big superhero landing would she later
fails big time on the bus this girl is dressed
like one of captain america's girls from his
uso shows this guy is wearing an actual captain
america costume with a shield the one on the right
is dressed like scarlet witch in avengers age of
ultron they have a super quick montage of bruno's
instagram account of them taking pictures with
all the different characters you see him dressed
up like a version of iron man the girl behind them
with the white hair in the braid seems like more
of an asgardian reference but if storm would have
already debuted in the mcu i'd say without the
braid she looks way closer to a version of storm
but like because this is meant to be a convention
for marvel avengers characters everyone is dressed
as some version of a marvel character like nick
fury vision these girls are even dressed like iron
man's girls from iron man 2 when he was on stage
you also notice when she's going through her
upstairs storage there's a bunch of stuff from her
childhood like she used to be in the girl scouts
there's also a childhood captain america drawing
that she made in the comics it was actually
captain america that told carol danvers she should
start calling herself captain marvel it seems
like the way they're explaining the kree band's
power is that they actually siphon energy from
light like when the light above starts flashing
it's like they're powering themselves up when the
flashes start going off in her face later in the
episode they really power up the bands i think
they're doing it that way so that when she's on
screen with captain marvel who's like this giant
cosmic battery she will have an infinite energy
source to power up her bands then like i said the
actual convention is like wall-to-wall references
there are a billion here that you could just pick
out so i'm just going to talk about some of the
bigger ones camp lehigh is where captain america
got the super soldier serum in the first movie
later in the timeline the 1970s they visited there
during the avengers in-game time heist it's also
where arnhem zola was hiding out in the computers
during winter soldier the hulk entrance that they
have here is designed based on classic hulk comic
book art and inside they're playing the theme song
from the 1940s captain america uso shows to
her wall-to-wall around the convention they
have different booths based on different events
for different avengers characters like there's a
giant hulk area there's a black widow an iron man
standing a giant viking thor area for asgardians
you see doctor strange in the background i mean
it's a convention so it's literally every avengers
character you could imagine i did not spot though
this is interesting i did not spot a bunch of
spider-man stuff specifically like no depictions
of him in the costume around this the funny thing
about this avengers con 2 is that kevin feige
said they had so much fun making this for the
series they might actually start doing it in real
life they have a big guardians of the galaxy area
there's another green woman in the background
cosplaying hulk another reminder that they're
doing she-hulk episodes later this summer like
oh by the way we're going to be having this other
series coming really soon too they have a joke
about america's ass with captain america's butt
the ant-man and the wasp table is actually using
the real life logo from the marvel movie they
even have a tribute wall for the dead avengers
characters like black widow and iron man people
have also hung up tributes to their own loved ones
here in references to other major events like this
one is yelling about the sokovia accords someone
is trying to sell a book that they wrote based on
the life of peter quill the title starboy story
is just a play on the idea that nobody knows or
remembers that he's calling himself star-lord like
who who are you what's your name all the comic
book covers here are based on actual comics they
have the iconic captain america phrase i can do
this all day the vendors even dress like an actual
ant for ant-man's worker ants all these pamphlets
that the black panther theme character is handing
out are travel brochures for visiting wakanda
they even have a giant installation depicting the
events of ant-man and the wasp with him going to
giant man form in the bay when she's staring at
the captain marvel booth the captain marvel theme
song starts playing and then her frenemy zoe shows
up in a non-canonical version of the costume the
trigger sir and they turn it into that big thing
like i said the big flash thompson joke about her
not caring about kamala khan but loving this new
mystery ms marvel character when bruno tells her
it's her time to shine literally he's talking
about the photon gloves but also she literally
shines when she's using her power of the mega
bands then the big easter egg that you probably
spotted here is for agent m so in real life agent
m has been working for marvel making videos for
them on their main channel for a long time so if
marvel really started doing these conventions he
would actually be doing this in real life when she
comes back bruno says that he's dressed as bruce
banner and even though it just seems like he's a
normal person wearing a lab coat he's wearing the
same types of flannel looking shirts that bruce
banner wears also right next to them you see the
woman cosplaying she-hulk just another easter
egg for the she-hulk episodes later this summer
when she puts the bangle on it expands and covers
her arm a little bit more you see the same type of
cosmic energy flow around her that you saw coming
off of monica rambo when the camera spins around
and you get that background shot that looks like
a flashback to a bunch of aliens it seems like
a bunch of creed that are connected to one of
the trailer scenes of people back in pakistan
walking single file it might have something to
do with what was going on with her grandma and
like i said the reason the band's power activates
is because it's leeching power from all the light
that's being given off around her that's why it's
only after all the camera flashes start going off
that she accidentally activates the power in just
like classic spider-man fashion she also creates
the mess that winds up leading to her having
to save the zoe character like she's actually
responsible for that happening in the first place
in the same way that spider-man causes a lot of
the problems that he winds up having to solve
during his movies the actual end credits for
the episode are meant to be a bunch of graffiti
and art for things during the series all around
jersey city but pretty much every panel that
you see here is based on an actual ms marvel
comic book panel they even have references
to her inhuman stretchy powers in the comics
she uses the word mbigen when she's doing that so
we'll see if she uses that later in the series too
then surprisingly they have an actual
post credit scene for those of you that
were disappointed that moon knight didn't really
have a ton of post credit scenes this time it's
a damage control scene with the same characters
that we just saw during spider-man no way home
seeing footage of her powers and investigating the
reason why the footage glitches out on the phone
of the person's upload is because of the effect of
the mega bands siphoning off that camera's power
so during episode 2 it's all about them trying to
haul her in to question her about her abilities
there'll be six episodes total we'll also get some
she-hulk trailers for this while this is going on
too also we just got a brand new thor loving
thunder trailer video that will be my next video
to post later today there are a billion other
easter eggs during the episode so you could
watch it like 50 times and still find new stuff
if there's anything big that you saw that i didn't
talk about during the video just write it below
in the comments my full ms marvel episode 2 video
will post next wednesday it should be back to a
relatively normal schedule now that things aren't
quite so crazy while you wait for everything
everyone click here for my full obi-wan kenobi
episode 4 video in easter eggs and click here for
that brand new black adam trailer video in easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!